cette semaine quels sont les enjeux
principaux pour les autochtones pendant
la campagne électorale fédérale
oui bienvenue à part à l'automne si
c'est mélissa pour répondre à la
question de jimmy cette semaine je dois
avouer qu'il va y avoir plusieurs enjeux
sur la table la première ça veut dire de
la participation des autochtones en
réserve
lors des élections fédérales pourquoi
est-ce que c'est un enjeu est ce parce
que la participation habituellement des
communautés autochtones est très basse
comparée à celle du tir de la population
canadienne
on n'a pas beaucoup l'habitude de voter
soit au provincial ou municipal
un peu plus au fédéral puisqu'on est un
enjeu fédéral
les premières nations et en sous la loi
des indiens et au cours des dernières
années on a eu une augmentation
justement de la participation des
communautés autochtones lors des
élections on a même vu une différence de
14% entre les élections de 2011 et celle
de 2015
pourquoi et bien parce que justement une
augmentation de la participation sur la
place publique
deux premiers mandats d'élu autochtone
des enjeux d'un côté beaucoup plus
discutés et beaucoup de promesses
justement ont été mis de l'avant qui
concernait directement à la communauté
autochtone certains de ces anges le sont
pas tout le temps évident à comprendre
puisque on a quand même je dirais deux
systèmes un peu parallèle le système
autochtone mais quand même
inclus dans l'idée politique canadienne
touche des enjeux qui ne toucheront pas
la population canadienne donc souvent
qu'on va en parler voire une confusion
dans ces enjeux le alors parce que juste
parce que le monde ont jamais compris ce
qui se passait dans les communautés
autochtones mais de plus en plus
l'intérêt augmente
et justement suite les élections de 2015
et beaucoup de promesses qui ont été
faites aux communautés autochtones ce
que fait augmenter la participation
autochtone maintenant mais il va y avoir
à rendre des comptes
justement à l'électeur autochtone donc
certains de ces enjeux de qui vont venir
sur la place publique savez les droits
territoriaux
quelle est la différence entre des
droits territoriaux canadiens et les
témoins territoriaux autochtone les
perspectives de développement économique
sur les communautés
comment faire justement du développement
économique sans nécessairement avoir à
dire oui à des projets qui sont
destructeurs sur le territoire on va
revenir sur des 94 appel à l'action de
la commission vérité réconciliation
parce que beaucoup de ses promesses
électorales de 2015 ont été basées sur
ces appels à l'action revoir la loi sur
les indiens restitution des pères
autochtone saucisses avait donné un jeu
assez chaud a discuté pendant les
élections
l'application de la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones
là je pense au projet de loi c 232 qui
est mort au feuilleton le projet de loi
de roméo saganash
parce que justement une promesse que
lors des prochaines élections
monsieur trudeau les ramènerait
justement ce projet de loi et
s'assurerait qu'il penserait mes leaders
on a senti cette promesse là dans le
passé est ce que ça veut dire que ça va
être une nouvelle promesse qui va être
renouvelée mais encore oublié après les
élections mais ça ça risque d'être un
enjeu qui va être fortement discutée et
surtout je pense beaucoup au retour sur
la sphère jodi white ribbon pourquoi
parce qu'il ya une grande confusion
justement sur est ce que c'est un enjeu
de partis politiques
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est à
l' interne du parti politique ou est ce
que c'est un enjeu autochtone pour
beaucoup de personnes dans le grand
public canadien c'était juste un
dangereux de partie alors que pour nous
dans les communautés c'était un enjeu
d'une femme autochtone qui était
présente et a été présenté d'ailleurs
pendant les élections comme étant un
représentant des communautés autochtones
donc de la tasse et malgré que ce soit
un an
je deux parties ça reste est pour nous
un enjeu de taille et les communautés
autochtones donc c'est pour ça aussi que
de la confusion lors de la fin et ça ça
va revenir beaucoup sur la place
publique et là j'en oublie sûrement
beaucoup parce qu'on va parler dont on
va parler d' extractives itie on a parlé
de beaucoup de choses mais je vous
dirais qu'il faut rester à l'écouté il
faut s'ouvrir justement à entendre les
nouveaux messages qui vont arriver sur
des plateformes publiques ou dans les
médias sur les questions autochtones et
surtout pour pas hésité à nous envoyer
des questions ou à demandez autour de
vous de quoi retourne ces enjeux le
plutôt que de faire des généralisations
alors j'espère jimmy avoir pu répondre
un petit peu à ta question et il n'était
pas justement à nous envoyer des
questions n'hésitez pas à partager ses
vidéos et là on vous souhaite une belle
semaine au nom de parole autochtone